Aliénor:
T'aurais pu faire un effort sur la tenue,
quand même, tout le monde se retourne pour te regarder
et à part ça c'est moi qui suis bizarre!
Lucretia:
Si tu penses que je vais revêtir ces vêtements
ridicules, tu te fourres le pilum dans le
rectu...
Aliénor:
Ouais, ben t'étonne pas si on te jette.
Et laisse-moi parler, au pire je dirai que
t'es ma sœur folle.
Aliénor:
Holà, tavernier! Servez-moi une pinte de...
Lucretia:
Nous sommes à la recherche d'une pirate,
et on nous a dit qu'elle se trouverait ici.
Aliénor:
C'est ma sœur folle, au fait.
Barman:
Astrid, je suppose? Elle est en bas.
Quand elle aura fini de vider mon stock, dites
lui qu'on l'appelle à la plonge.
Aliénor:
Merci l'ami!
Lucretia:
Draco dormiens nunquam titillandus.
Barman:
Et, euh, consommez pas surtout.
Vivement les vacances...
Aliénor:
Yohooo!
Lucretia:
Bonjour, Astrid.
Astrid:
Barrez-vous.
Aliénor:
Eh écoute tes aînées, on vient juste discuter.
Astrid:
J'suis sérieuse.
Barrez-vous, maintenant.
J'veux pas de problèmes et VOUS vous avez
une gueule à problèmes.
Lucretia:
Nous avons juste quelques questions à te poser.
Astrid:
T'es sourde la romaine? Rentrez chez la prof,
j'veux pas être mêlée à vos histoires,
ça me regarde plus.
Lucretia:
Écoute, nous sommes toutes coincées hors
de notre époque sans savoir pourquoi.
Aliénor:
Moi j'me souviens même plus comment j'ai atterri ici !
Lucretia:
A en croire ta réaction, tu en sais plus
que nous, alors dis-nous ce que tu sais!
Aliénor:
Steuplé.
Et ensuite promis, on disparaît.
Astrid:
Vous avez un de ces culots de venir ici, vous
savez qu'on est en danger de mort?
Aliénor et Lucrétia:
QUOI / PARDON?
Astrid:
Et vous vous promenez en plein jour sans même
faire attention.
Bon j'vous explique ce qui se passe, mais
c'est vraiment pour que vos conneries
me retombent pas dessus.
Aliénor:
Franchement, ça me va.
Lucretia:
On t'écoute.
Astrid:
Déjà, on est bloquées ici parce que notre
transfert a merdé, vous vous en doutiez.
Le problème avec la cyber-historienne qui
nous a contactées, c'est qu'elle ignorait
qu'elle avait déjà une historienne dans
ses ancêtres.
La Prof.
Du coup, ça a fait capoter toute l'opération,
certains ancêtres ont atterri au XXIIIe siècle,
d'autres chez la Prof, on sait pas pourquoi.
Aliénor:
Comment tu sais ça?
Astrid:
J'ai discuté avec les autres, tous ceux que
j'ai pu trouver.
Lucretia:
Donc tu ne t'es pas isolée loin de tout le
monde comme tu sembles le prétendre! Où
sont les autres?
Astrid :
Morts.
Ou peut-être encore en fuite, pour certains.
Depuis que je me cache, je sais pas trop.
Aliénor:
Attends, tu te caches, tu te caches, mais
ça a été SUPER facile pour moi de te trouver...
Astrid:
J'suis une pirate.
Dans un bar.
Ça passe tout seul.
Lucretia:
Qui veut nous tuer?
Astrid:
Les cyber-historiens.
On en sait trop pour rentrer chez nous, on
perturbe le continuum espace-temps en étant
ici, et on leur est plus d'aucune utilité
puisqu'on a vu une autre époque que la notre
maintenant, notre témoignage serait forcément
biaisé.
Aliénor:
Mais... Mais...
Astrid:
Par exemple, toi la gueuse,
tu parlerais de ton époque, tes
rois et tout, mais en sachant que quelques
siècles plus tard la monarchie prend fin
et des tas de choses changent.
Ça biaiserait forcément ton témoignage.
Enfin je dis pas que ça justifie qu'on nous
traque et nous tue, mais
pour les cyber-historiens, c'est le cas.
Alors autant se planquer, et boire, vous devriez
en faire autant.
Aliénor:
Comment...
Astrid:
Tout ça, j'le sais surtout grâce à un agent
de la Cyber-histoire que j'ai chopé l'autre
jour.
Il avait été envoyé ici pour me tuer, vous
voyez le tableau.
Lucretia:
Pourrions-nous l'interroger?
Astrid:
Plus maintenant, il doit commencer à être
rongé par les vers, ça doit pas être beau
à voir.
Mais j'l'ai fait parler avant de le transformer
en ragoût, donc je sais tout ça, et donc
je vous conseille de vous planquer.
Vous êtes clairement pas de taille à leur
faire face, surtout toi  avec ta robe de six pieds de long.
Donc laissez-moi me débrouiller avec ça et...
Faites-vous discrètes.
Aliénor:
Eh non attends, s'il y a de la bagarre je
veux en être! Je tiens bien à profiter
du XXIe siècle tant que je suis là, et sans
risquer de me faire tuer à chaque coin de
rue si possible.
Lucretia:
Pour ce que tu sors.
De mon côté, j'étais censée faire un rapide
tour au XXIIIe siècle, rentrer chez moi,
et me marier.
Alors pas question de moisir ici.
Si nous sommes les trois ancêtres de la Prof
restantes, soit, nous nous battrons ensemble!
Astrid:
Ok, ok, moins fort...
J'me suis acheté un téléphone, ici...
Débrouillez-vous pour en trouver un aussi.
Vous m'envoyez le numéro, je vous appelle
si j'ai des infos, et pendant ce temps là
vous ne faites rien de stupide.
Que j'aie pas à le regretter.
Aliénor:
Je vois pas pourquoi tu dis ça.